It's survival of the fittest.
And you've been transported
into a real life
death game where everyone has
superpowers, including you,
and the only way to escape
the game is to kill or die.
What do you do? I'm
going to break down the mistakes made.
What you should do and how to beat
the death game in Darwin's game.
Kaname is chilling at school
when he receives a text from a friend
inviting him to play a free to play game
on his phone called Darwin's Game.
Before anyone can say anything,
he clicks on the game only to find a snake
magically come out of the phone
to bite him, causing him to pass out
later at the school nurse's office.
He says he's not feeling too good
and decides to head home on the train.
He checks out Darwin's game a second time
and accidentally
begins a match with a man
dressed in a panda costume.
All of a sudden, that very same panda
man in real life
comes towards him and tries to kill him,
forcing Kaname to get off the train
and run for his dear life with no one
to help and Kanamein a dead end.
He says his prayers
until his best friend saves him
just in the nick of time,
getting hurt in the process.
He and the injured best friend
hide from panda man.
When we learned that Darwin's
game is actually real and that there are
a few rules to this game, we can't call
emergency services during the game.
We can only contact the outside world
through the phone app itself,
and that our general location
can become visible to the enemy.
When we use our phones during a match,
and that sucks for Kaname
because he accidentally reveals
his location to panda man
when he checks a mysterious text
he receives from an unknown girl .
This causes panda man
to comfort their throats and forces
kind of me to learn the most important
rule of all that in order to survive,
we either need to hide until the timer
runs out or take out our opponent
by sheer luck and a little bit of skill,
but mostly luck.
Kaname survives and beats
Pennyman, but also loses
his best friend in the process. Man.
And here I thought the only thing pandas
could harm were piles of bamboo.
Kaname had the right idea,
but executed it poorly.
We should have used the environment
who are advantage more and ran
headfirst into crowded areas
like busy streets or nearby malls .
This may not have stopped panda man,
but the more people he has to kill in
order to get to me might cause enough
of the public to panic to where I can
either blend in with the fleeing crowds
or be saved by nearby on duty
police officers.
If the route forbids me from finding
any nearby populated areas, then
instead of politely panicking to nearby
officers, I would take a swing at them
and steal their sidearm piece
to defend myself.
As it's obvious from the encounter
Kaname has with that police officer
that he is packing heat.
Now, our friends
showing up was a welcome addition,
but he's losing blood
and is now officially a waste of space.
No offense. So I'd say let's leave him
and find some nearby drinks from either
a vending machine or nearby store
along with a fire extinguisher
having the bottles of liquids.
Well, allow us to stop handyman's
camouflage ability
by splashing him with the stuff,
allowing us to see the now
wet outline of his body
and the footprints to go along with it.
Or if shit hits the fan like now.
And thanks to that cop,
Pennyman is now armed and invisible.
So our savers play
will be the fire extinguisher,
which we can use by hiding behind a door
or an empty room with only one exit.
Wait until the door opens by itself
and then blast him in the face
with some good ol CO2 temporarily
blinding his vision
, allowing us to knock him out
with the fire extinguisher itself
and then smashing his brains in.
Back at home, Kaname realizes
he can order weapons straight
from the online store within the app
as a pistol magically appears at his door.
Out of thin air.
Perfect timing as he receives a text
from that mysterious girl from before
who asks him to come to meet her
in exchange for information
about Darwin's game itself.
Kaname then heads
to an abandoned warehouse
where he meets a girl named Shuka,
who tells him that she'll spill the beans
only if he proves he's trustworthy
by showing her his superpower or Segel,
as they call it,
which are superpowers
that each member in Darwin's game
randomly gets when they join,
which could be anything.
Bad news for Kaname, though, as he doesn't
know what the hell she's talking about,
which angers Shuka and causes her
to challenge Kanamemyia to a death match.
Although good thing for Kaname
and his quick thinking as he blinds Shuka
with a self-defense flashlight
and makes a break for it in the process,
we also get to see what Shuka powers are
as she terrifyingly chases
Kaname around the warehouse.
That is, until he somehow
unlocks his Segal,
which turns out to be the very same pistol
he got earlier, creating it
from his hands out of thin air,
thanks to Kaname and his smarts.
He manages to defeat Shuka
and win the match, and he decides
to spare her life, which is technically
not against the rules.
Unfortunately for him,
all of this superpower
stuff wears Kanamemyia down
and he passes out right after.
Oh, this girl is a firecracker
and downright terrifying and awfully rude.
So therefore, she must.
I Kaname finally revealed his single,
which looks like the M9 Beretta firearm
he ordered from earlier hand
from Shuka Speed,
she seems to be able to dodge
anything we fire at her.
This means to close the gap between us,
our bullets and her sweet face.
We need to blind her or surprise her,
because this will ensure
she will be unable
to effectively dodge our attacks.
I would cut the power the same way
Kaname did, except hide between the boxes
and cargo within the warehouse,
forcing Shuka to come closer towards us.
Her being blinded will result in her
being unable to know from which direction
the bullet comes from,
and therefore will be unable to use her
super quick reflexes to dodge it.
And we only need one well-timed shot.
So I say, let's empty the mag
into the girl and see what happens later.
Kaname wakes up to and
revealing Shuka,
who convinces Kaname
to start a clan with her within the game,
joining forces basically
as they head for a walk,
she reveals to Kaname
more information about the game.
Winning matches gives you points
that you can use to spend on safe
shelters, food, weapons
and real life cash.
Although you cannot talk about Darwin's
game in public or risk being teleported
from the game during their time out,
Kaname's phone also gets stolen by a young
spiky haired guy who also informs us
that we can't play the game with someone
else's phone, although our phone
can get destroyed by anyone.
Meaning, if that happens,
this would result in the player
being unable to buy or seek
safe shelter, as well as never know
when they're being battled.
They also want to be able
to search or communicate through text or
call with anyone, leaving them isolated.
You'd basically be royally screwed.
But thankfully, this leap
has got some manners as spiky haired
guy challenges kind of made the good old
fashioned way with a death match.
And of course, Kaname like before stumbles
along, getting lucky right at the end.
Yet again, by using his last minute
single to stun spiky haired guy,
almost destroying his phone
and winning the match
right before they are teleported to join
an event known as the treasure hunt game.
OK, spiky haired
guy is young and ambitious.
I'll give him that.
And let's thank him
for not using his single powers on us,
because this just makes it
that much easier
since we can't rely on our single powers
to work effectively.
We must rely on our bodies, anatomy,
namely our fists and his groin.
Softer areas like the throat, eyes
and groin work wonders for most people.
If you hit them hard enough.
And I'm willing to bet my career
that it'll work on this teenage punk.
I'm going to focus on closing the gap
between us and spiky hair dude.
Therefore, we should consider
getting punched a couple of times, forcing
spiky hair due to enter our arms lengths
to keep him distracted
and be within our striking distance.
The right after.
I would aim for a shot straight too.
As moneymakers, as hard as I can
with an uppercut to his nether regions.
Using our legs would be preferable
and would allow us to drive more force
towards the area
than aim for the area between spiky hair,
dudes, belly button and Johnson,
as this will almost certainly cause him
to hunched forward,
whether it's for a brief second or for
longer, likely causing him to fall over.
If he's weak enough,
then we can use our signal as well.
And then I tease him
repeatedly for good measure,
then crush his throat with my foot. What?
There's no rules in fight club Kaname
suddenly appears at a hotel just in time
for the treasure hunt game as he gets
instructions on the game itself.
Find the hidden treasure
located around Shibu
and get as many points as possible
within the 24 hour limit.
Killing players while
in the game will not grant you any death
match points. And all players
must collect at least three rings
before the game ends or they die.
Kaname running out of the room, bumps
into machine gun guy as he gets hunted
around the hotel floor, trapped as
the only way out is through the elevators.
Kaname finally gets cornered
and is forced to give up
whatever rings he has on him
and machine gun guy lets him
live and leaves in the elevator
right after he meets Smart Girl
who tells him that the elevator is a trap
set up by someone we'll call plant guy because he has plant powers.
And smart girl suggests that they team up
in order to survive, and Kaname agrees.
We also learn smart girls power
is the ability to know the location
and movement of all matter in the world,
which means she can basically dodge
anything that comes at her
or fire any gun and know
the movement of the bullet 100 percent .
Suddenly they run into machine
gun guy again and other gang members
who look to be under plant
guy's mind control
as they begin to chase down Kaname.
And smart girl, both of them try to hide
and destroy all the hotel floor cameras
as they have a feeling plant
guy is watching and they managed to hide
in a hotel room as the two are hunted down
relentlessly by plant guy's minions.
Kaname and smart girl
had to plan and order some grenades off
the phone's endgame app
and then began getting to work.
Smart girl distracts the minions
with an explosion as Kaname uses
the fire extinguisher rope in the hotel
hallway to climb down past the floor
, set with plant guys traps
and he reaches the bottom floor safely.
I'm starting to like smart girl.
And she seems like a valuable member
to have in terms of information gathering
and reconnaissance, although she kind of
dropped the ball here a little bit.
I would use the in-game shop
to order me a box of 12 grenades,
two flash bangs and two.
If we can have things delivered
straight to our feet, almost magically,
we should have used the in-game store
more effectively.
We could have explored more
what the in-game shop had to offer
and perhaps have bought other items
that could have helped us
in this situation.
There's nowhere to go.
And Machine Gun guy
here seems to be packing
the biggest weapon,
sporting a Russian RPG light machine gun.
And those things don't mess around.
So we really can't fight them
head on effectively.
So once again, the element of surprise
will be our biggest edge.
I would plant a box of six grenades,
minus one for us as we plant one box
in the corner of each of the hotels,
two staircases where we know plant
guys minions will be coming from.
Then I'd have Kanamelly
to camp out on one staircase
while having smart girl
camp out on the other one.
Once the two minions come down between
each of the staircases, I toss a flash
bang, blinding them, then toss a single
grenade towards each of the two boxes,
catching the minions by surprise
and setting off a massive chain explosion
within each of the hotel staircases,
killing all of the minions in the process.
Afterward, all we need to do is simply
rappel down the window with our ropes.
No fuss Kaname on the ground floor
suddenly runs into plant guy
and has no choice
but to battle him face to face.
This is when he realizes that
unless he does something different,
he will soon die as planned.
Guy clearly outranks
him in power and endurance,
but all of a sudden he looks out as he
discovers a new trick to his SAGOL power,
which is if he cuts his weapons
lifespan shorter,
he can effectively increase
the internal pressure of his bullet
rounds, increasing their firepower
by an additional 10 percent.
This 10 percent increase in power proves
to be effective as Kaname manages
to break through plant guy
shield and defeats another opponent yet
again, this time with a little less luck
and a little more skill.
All right. We finally learned
how to control our powers
and figured out some tricks.
Now we're pretty much
cornered and outmatched.
So I think the safest option
would be to run.
Kaname has been using his powers
for a while, and he has already stated
that he's exhausted.
So realistically,
I doubt we'd have enough endurance
to keep going on for much longer.
Which is why we need some space
and time to think.
I would hide within
one of the many hiding spots in the hotel.
Then I would load up on items
such as grenades,
flash bangs, even a knife,
although I would see
if we could use our power
to create them all at once.
But if this doesn't work, then
during our few moments of peace and quiet,
I would use my time to check the Endgame
App Store and see just
what else we could get
and if we could find specialty ammunition.
RPG machine gun uses 762 ammunition.
So I would look in the store
for specialty rounds like high explosive
incendiary rounds or even an actual full
metal jacket round designed to pierce
through and take out plant guy's armor.
Checkmate, buddy.
After the match, Kaname decides
to keep that man alive and smart.
Go recruit him and machine gun
guy from earlier to form an alliance
as there's a rumor
that an even bigger threat
will be coming to the hotel very soon,
namely the famous and ruthless aIthe clan
who are looking to win
Darwin's game and kill whoever
and however many people
it takes to achieve their goals.
Kaname, along with Machine Gun Guy,
then head off to find Shuka,
who sends them a mysterious help
text from the subway on the way there.
They run into a tiny little human
who has ice powers call her Elsa,
and Kaname dives into the Waterfield
subway to find a helpless shuka.
Once saved, they find out that it was
that strange little girl,
Elsa, who trapped Shuka
and thanks to Elsa, split personality.
She has two powers as part of her Segal,
one being her power to manipulate bodies
of water and the other. The power of ice.
Luckily for Elsa, Shuka decides
to show some mercy because of her
split personality and spare Elsa's life
for almost killing her.
And so they end up recruiting her
into their alliance, just as they find out
from Smart Girl that the rings everybody's
collecting are not the real treasure.
So Kaname and the group set off to find
Smart Girl, along with the real treasure
while plant guy stays behind at the hotel
to take on part of the eighth clan.
But as their bad luck would have it,
they reached the subway only to find
that smart girl has been taken hostage
by some of the members of the 8th clan.
Wasting no time, Kaname
and his group Batlow aIthe clan as Shuka
Safe, smart girl who then goes
to try and locate the real treasure.
Sadly for machine gun guy
during the battle,
his hand gets chopped off
by the leader of the eighth clan.
Dreadlocks guy Kaname is then forced
to bluff his way into saving him
just as he, thanks to Smart Girl,
finds the real treasure in a locker
right next to everybody.
This results in Kaname in his group
winning the match and saving machine
gun guy as the treasure hunt game
officially ends.
Now, in this situation,
we finally have our team of superheroes.
And so this is where
some better leadership from Kaname
would have come in handy for one.
Our group should not be split up entirely,
but rather have taking cover
nearby as one unit.
I then ordered Smart Girl
to place her sights on dreadlocks guy
from a distance and wait for my orders.
Dreadlock guys, teleportation powers
make him fast and nimble.
And so we want to try and injure him
or prevent him from teleporting altogether
first before taking him out in this.
Case our biggest powerhouse.
Believe it or not, is Elsa,
as she is one of the few
who can take on dreadlocks guy head on.
I would order Shuka to tag
all the majority of grunts
with her powers, as she does so with ease.
Then I'd have also get her water
from the nearby train bathroom
to take out the rest of the henchmen.
From here, we have two options.
One also floods the metro and takes out
everybody, including dreadlocks guy.
Elsa would need to create
a sphere wall made of water around
dreadlocks guy up to 20 meters
thick in width and height,
preventing dreadlocks, guys, teleportation
abilities from teleporting him
out of the water prison.
As we have seen from his attacks,
the furthest dreadlocks guy
can teleport is up to 10 meters.
So if our water sphere is larger
in width and height,
then we could effectively capture him.
I would then scare the shit out of Elsa
and to have her evil twin come out to play
and turn that entire sphere of water
into a giant ice fall
prison freezing and capturing
dreadlocks guy entirely.
The second option would be to have Elsa
take out the henchmen and dreadlocks
guy with a giant wave of water
filling up the subway.
Then like a wave on a beach wash
dreadlocks guy right up in near
Smart Girl and she takes him out with her
bolt action sniper rifle.
The confusion from being tossed around
from a giant water wave and overwhelmed
should be enough to distract
dreadlocks guy from teleporting
for at least a few seconds, which
we can use to our advantage and kill him.
Two months later, after the competition,
Kaname uses his connections and prize
money to get himself in shape by training
with another group called the Danijel
Boxing Club, where they train Kaname
and surgically fix machine gun guy's hand.
This is also an Kaname looks into
making an alliance with the club itself.
However, the leader of dancehall
boxing club, Mr.
Muscles, says that he must first fight
Kaname to see if he's worthy of forming an
alliance with Kaname, follows his wishes
and challenges him to a friendly match.
But of course, Mr.
Muscles doesn't take it easy on Kaname
and almost beats him
without even using his single power.
But luckily, Kaname narrowly defeats Mr.
Muscles, winning the match
and successfully securing an alliance
with Don JLB Boxing Club.
Hey, I like Mr. Muscles.
He's arguably one of the best opponents
in the game and someone I definitely
don't want to mess with.
But since we have to,
I would have like to end the match sooner
than Kaname did by cheating a little bit.
I would have used the time before the
match to excuse myself to the restroom,
to order a little bit of everything
from the in-game shop, like grenades,
flash bangs, flame throwers,
whatever I can get my hands on.
This way, we could have saved up
all of our single power for the match
as even before the match started .
It's obvious we're going to need all
of our strength since we last saw Kaname.
He has definitely picked up some moves.
And if we take inventory, we now have
knives, grenades, flash bangs and RPG
machine gun and M9 pistol and a machete
and even a scorpion submachine gun.
That is frickin awesome.
Although I would have begun the match
by attacking Mr.
Muscles with any one of my guns.
I would have waited like Kaname did
until I trex Mr.
Muscles into revealing to me
his power with a grenade.
I would have then, as my last trick,
halved my firearms lifespan in order
to increase my power output by 10 percent.
Like Kaname did with Plant Guy earlier,
this would have either taken Mr.
Muscles completely out or forced him
to use his power to defend himself.
If this happened,
then I would have used this brief moment
to flashbang him
and then close the distance
with my machete to his throat.
As of this point, we've only attacked him
from afar up until now.
And maybe we could stab Azat
if we can't cut through his flesh
and at least blind him a little bit.
Kaname's victory is suddenly cut short
as long haired girl shows up
just in the nick of time to knock
everybody out and kidnaps Kanamemyia.
Later, he wakes up in the limo of the long
haired girl Darwin's games.
No one player, but we find out, is part
of a family of generational assassins.
Scared Kaname has little choice
until we find out that Shuka and Kaname's
clan follow close-by unconsummated tale
fearful for their lives.
He makes a deal with long haired
girl, the deal being
if she can successfully escape from them
without killing anyone,
the Kaname will do as she requests.
Thankfully, this kid's got himself
a good teammate.
A Shuker calls upon long haired girl
and they battle it
out on the roof of their cars,
along with the rest of Kaname's team
as they managed to stop long haired
girls car in time,
making this terrifying assassin
lose the bet against Kaname, forcing
longhaired girl to join forces with them.
There was no reason to fight
as long as they did when the entire wager
of condoms bet with long haired
girl rested on their transportation.
If we stopped long haired girls car from
driving away, then how will she escape?
And if she doesn't manage to successfully
escape that, that means we'd win the bet.
So this really means this whole time
that they should have been focusing
on the tires of her car almost exclusively
as Shuka battles it out with long haired
girl and keeps her distracted.
I would order Smart Girl
to take position with her sniper
rifle atop the roof of their Humvee
and then using smart girl
single power of knowing the positioning
of all matter in the world.
She'd be able to aim
and perfectly position
her shot right into the rear
wheel of long haired girls limo, disabling
the car entirely.
That's assuming their car doesn't
have run on flat tires, which are tires
that are self supporting and.
Once that you can continue driving on
for miles after they are punctured.
If this was the case, then no worries.
All we'd have to do
is simply tell long haired girls car
until their tire finally gives out.
Or we could simply love
tap right into them, burn out style
until they simply crash and die
in a ball of beautiful flames
later on at the apartment.
The worst news arrives at their doorstep.
Economize closest school friend
has been kidnaped by the 8th clan
who are holding him hostage.
And if Kaname wants to save him,
he'll have to go find him himself.
We then get word from Smart Girl
that she's found out
where the eighth Clance base is and where
they're holding economize friend
and with no contact from long haired girl
or available support from their friends
over a Donnghaile boxing club.
Kaname's group leaves to go save
his friend without any reinforcements.
Later, they arrive at the warehouse
only to find the gang in the midst
of fighting with the police.
And they use this opportunity
to try and help economize, friend.
The team splits up as Kaname and machine
gun guy enter the back of the warehouse
only to find economize friend dead
and packaged up all neatly in a box.
This being the last straw, Kanamelly loses
it and ends up killing
the rest of the eighth clans,
grunts and soldiers along with machine gun
guy as sugar defeats dreadlocks guy
using some new tricks up her sleeve
Kaname hat his tactics down pat
but could have used some finessing.
Sending a phone down to her friend
to let him join Darwin's game and become
the ultimate distraction was genius.
But unfortunately,
we couldn't do anything to save him
as he was already dead
the moment he entered that warehouse.
Now, we know from Smart Girl
Scouting that there are about 15 members
around that warehouse.
But truly, I wouldn't even concern myself
with what's going on with most of them,
as there's only one member worthy enough
that we should kill.
Going in at close
range was ballsy but unnecessary.
I would have ordered Smart
to take the vantage point from the roof
as there are no guards up there,
and she'll have a bird's eye
view of the whole warehouse.
Then I'd order Kaname and machine gun
guy to go in big through the back door
and create all sorts of firepower
noise with a solid distraction
in place and dreadlocks.
Guy is surely distracted.
I'd command smart girl to fire around
straight into a sweet, sweet face.
Smart girl with her
long range and her stigall power means
she'll be our most accurate shooter.
And if we go the ways of Joe Exotic
and employ some fancier looking ammunition
like the three three eight Lapolla Magnum
designed to penetrate
five layers of military body armor
at a stunning 1000 meters and
still be able to kill you in the process.
But also, I probably get smart girl
to equip a muzzle brake
or something like that.
So she's like three foot five
and this round has quite the kick with the
entirety of the eighth clan
finished Kaname finally kills
the human stomp called Dreadlocks Guy
by putting a bullet right through his gray
matter as he looks on into the distance,
ashamed of his friend's death,
making it his mission to find the game
master of this living hell
and put an end to Darwin's game
once and for all.
Along with the help of his
new clan and now also family.
And if you're into a family like this guy,
then I highly suggest
you subscribe for dear
life down below Downbelow,
let us know what you like,
what you didn't like.
But before all that,
I want to introduce you to our family.
Check out the video, guy.
Oh, he's a wizard.
Whoo! He's up there. He's pretty cool.
Check out dumb. He likes pens.
I don't know why. On behalf of everyone
from how to be the enemy.
Thank you so much for watching our videos.
And we love the support.
Let's get to 100000 subscribers.
Oh, my gosh. It's so frickin exciting.
Let's do it. See ya